at 10 58 a.m computers
around the world said no dozens of
websites went down
as an online outage caused major digital
disruption
lots of people saw this infamous 503
error
message which means nothing to anyone
apart from technologists like us that
understand what those error codes mean
and basically it meant that the server
that would normally
give you this local content served very
close to you
couldn't actually really work out what
it was meant to do
and where it was meant to go in order to
get the content
the culprit a company virtually no one
had heard of
called fastly which provides content
delivery networks
or cdns here's how they work
running a website takes lots of
information and it can often slow down
people get impatient when things take a
long time to load
so content delivery networks such as
fastly will store information about a
site in clusters
these clusters are distributed around
the world in pops
or points of presence these reduce
delays
and improve speed and connectivity
but if websites rely on just one content
delivery network
if it goes wrong you have a problem the
internet was built to be decentralized
but because so many of us use it it is
such a
you know global um amount of
connectivity
that actually has become more and more
centralized and the more centralized
it's become the more we have these
single points of failure
fastly said a service configuration
triggered disruptions across their pops
globally
they disabled the configuration and
within an hour things were working
but when you're dealing with the
internet every millisecond matters
our lives couldn't function without
technology
which is why it's almost remarkable so
few of us
understand how the internet works let
alone the
system of servers that help us access it
and that's why many are questioning how
one little-known company
could have such a huge impact on so many
high-traffic websites
laura bundock sky news